cela fera 100 ans cette année que le
concours miss france a été créée une
longévité qui en fait le plus ancien
concours de beauté au monde toujours en
activité nous permet maintenant à donner
une attaque et et c'est en 1920 que
cette cérémonie voit le jour pour la
toute première fois
d'abord sous le nom la plus belle femme
de france il faudra attendre 1987 pour
que la cérémonie soit télévisé cette
année est donc une année importante pour
le comité miss france qui avait pour
ambition d'organiser l'événement le 12
décembre prochain
sauf que voilà avec le confinement et
les incertitudes concernant le virus le
comité a fait le choix de reporter
l'événement au 19 décembre soit une
semaine plus tard
enfin patiente très impatiente un
changement très léger qui montre
l'optimisme de sylvie tellier
on sait déjà que cette année le jury
sera composé que d'anciennes miss de
quoi relancer la rivalité légendaire qui
existe entre plusieurs de ces reines de
beauté c'est pour faire un petit peu un
petit peu de base et côté des audiences
la cérémonie se porte bien mais son coût
est exorbitant
la société miss france facturerait
chaque année 2 7 millions d'euros à tf1
c'est quand même assez grave
dernier point cette cérémonie devrait se
dérouler au puy du fou
mais comment faire avec le public date
repoussée engagements financiers
colossaux incertitudes alors miss france
le concours doit-il être annulé delphine
wespiser miss france 2012 est avec nous
pour en parler allez restons pour parler
de solution magique elle est là avec
nous elle elle était déjà revenue en
fait delphine avant même qu on pas que
ce sujet avait déjà prévu d'être plus
c'est un hasard et 1 100 euros asa alors
est-ce que le combo miss france doit-il
être annulée gilles verdez vous avez des
infos exclusives que vous nous donnerez
bien entendu courant de semaine
prochaine
oui ce combat-là annulés au départ en ce
moment les gens ont besoin de ça alors
qu'il du public ou pas c'est un
spectacle pour les gens qui regardent la
télévision encore une fois c'est ceux
qui sont chez rue qui vont être punis
donc oui non il faut qu'ils aient cette
cérémonie du pot-au-noir foucault c'est
une très bonne chose
après bon il y aura moins de public
c'est pas très grave étant donné le goût
de la mer non moi je pense pas qu'il
fallait y aller moi je propose me solo
grave parce qu'il faut absolument pas
l'aligner parce que je pense que les
gens en ont besoin justement
donc les gens et en fait elles viennent
pas dans les zones où l'eau pas
exactement nos logis parce que là
malheureusement même si la date est
prévue mais ferrer or confinement nombre
à m'étonner des confiné et il ya
l'élection eh ben moi je pense que c'est
pas une bonne idée parce que le but de
ceux des consignes essaie de bien se
confiner pas faire la même erreur comme
hammam
donc je pense qu'on devrait si ça doit
avoir lieu pour les gens aux familles
dans l'eau gras s'améliora kindy qui
veut parler
les chaussettes wibert hanicotte jamais
vu c'est un truc des miss france c'est
un des shows événementielles comme
l'eurovision à dire on a besoin d'une
paillettes on a le renoir les filles qui
voyage aux caraïbes avec les petits
portraits des tirs entre il ya les
publics et rien n'est pas de c'est plus
un événement ya pas de caraïbes
donc pourquoi quel est l'intérêt de
regarder vous avez une au courant qu'il
ya un virus
ici dit ou non mais c'est pas possible
vous vous rendez compte ils veulent
absolument un public pourquoi est ce que
les nrj music awards ce sera le 5
décembre ce sera sans public et le ils
auront droit
non mais non je suis pas dans des
comptes les 29 prétendantes au titre le
public il y aura aussi tout le comité
miss france au moins 80 personnes
elle veut ramener en plus sylvie tellier
30 ancienne miss et d'ailleurs elles
veulent boycotter cette invitation est
boycottée donc vous imaginez dans la
salle des mousquetaires
donc si tu vas arriver avec airbus avec
30 nissui 30 anciens glisse et
d'ailleurs je voulais dire le chauffeur
mais non mais c'est pas possible ça fait
beaucoup trop non il suffit d'une
personne infectée et c'est l'effet
domino mais la propagation du virus mais
non dans la vie de delphine quand même
oui alors donc juste avant j'avais la
chargée de communication de chez miss
france qui m'a dit qu'une elle
comprenait pas cette date parce que ni
miss france ni tf1 n'a validé ni le 12
décembre
ni le 19 et apparemment ça vient du
parisien du journal le parisien dont ils
comprennent pas et ensuite miss france
respectera le soir de l'événement barre
et spectral en terme sanitaire doit que
voilà pour l'instant pas du tout public
ce sera en fonction lorsqu'on s'approche
alors de la mission préféré exactement
et moi j'ai lu personnes du comité donc
en toute objectivité je peux vous dire
que c'est bien une émission dont on se
fout qui est du public ou pas mais la
nation où c'est à bâle élections s'en
fout la jolie ont sont priori pas de
jury par l'anac c'est une émission au
regard on vote pour notre région et
cetera c'est un spectacle comme ça y'a
pas besoin
oui moi je suis absolument d'accord pour
une fois avec mon ami jamie selmer mois
le tulle demi français et couilles canu
publie pas moi je regarde les namas tous
les feux jolie elle avait au moins tu
regardes débat la force à changer des
têtes le coma à l'omr dur pour moi c'est
pas très chaud les années 30 comme des
kenny elles peuvent être élan dans des
écrans non mais où on voudra mais les
missiles faut qu'elle soit devant mieux
sur y étaient tous effectivement le
public on s'en tamponne
alors alors c'est à dire qu'on peut pas
parce que prévu s'il ya besoin de
beaucoup de staff les besoins de mathieu
d'habillement a priori je vous le dit
lui-même dont confirmé pour le 19
décembre oui voilà miss france se
passera bien le 19 décembre
ça a été confirmé en c'est sûr ce sera
en direct 19 décembre
j'espère que ce sera pas la dernière de
jean pierre parce que jean pierre g
super six il peut m'appeler aussie peut
me dire par ethernet et une rumeur qui
dit que jean-pierre voudrait faire sa
dernière puisque c'est les sens en 2006
et qu'il irait pour terminer voilà pour
la pour les 100 ans de miss france en
tous cas la pierre si c'est ta décision
sache que je ne suis pas d'accord et
emerson ici est d'accord on veut que tu
continues gilles verdez des infos sur
mille francs alors effectivement ce sera
le 19 décembre donc le comité miss
france a proposé sa tf1 qui a accepté
l'idée c'est que peut-être le 19
décembre a eu un déconfinement ça
permettrait à permettrait les vacances
de noël la trêve c'est ce que c'est ce
qu'ont dit les gens ils oublient
peut-être qui aura en fait mis de france
et grâce au concours miss france on va
peut-être savoir qu'il y aura des
consignes orales 1 c'est ce que j'ai vu
circuler sur les réseaux sociaux il dit
les gens sont trop forts hinault dernier
le concours miss france 19 décembre est
ce que ça veut pas dire qu'ils ont des
avantages abonnés bah ouais c'est ça
alors les miss sont convoqués deux
semaines et demie avant à paris toutes
les candidates elles seront testés et
emmenés au puy du fou est placé cinq
testé par qui oui et pressé sept jours à
l'isolément
d'accord y aura donc on les met
directement en prison affluent une
chambre comme la floride eu d'accord
plus bas très bas
c'est pour ça qu'ils regardaient de puy
du fou parce qu'il ya des chambres
individuelles possible au caramel chez
moi jveux
c'est vrai c'est un isolement le udyr
alors il ya beaucoup de polémiques quand
même parce que c'est les 100 ans de miss
france ça oui et beaucoup de miss vont
effectivement décidé de ne pas y aller
parce que on le comité miss france
boycott ostensiblement xavier geneviève
de fontenay et sylvie tellier fait
semblant de vouloir inviter geneviève de
fontenay
donc j'ai vu un échange de propos entre
sylvie tellier et geneviève de fontenay
le disait quoi aux villes où ça va si
vite et lydia geneviève de fontenay
voyez il est derrière vous ah oui je me
rends compte ça c'est sylvie tellier et
geneviève de fontenay j'aime c'est vous
qui êtes parti en claquant la porte
alors arrêtez d'essayer de me donner des
leçons et encore moins de m'insulter
vous avez dépassé les bornes
je me rends compte que vous êtes une
personne méchante qui ne vit que dans la
rancoeur rien ça c'est donc je n'étais
ni exactement mais elle a répondu je ne
l a pas répondu à ça c'est une grosse
hypocrisie quand elle dit espérer que
geneviève de fontenay
[Musique]
alors ensuite il ya quand même une vraie
polémique sur la photo je sais pas si
vous étiez à la femme elle a autant
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
le fond il ya une photo de classe de
miss oui toujours début de semaine
dernière à la plaine-saint-denis voyez
derrière un volant olalalala ah oui ça
me prive de 10 rennes dernière à la
plaine saint denis nous étions en plein
confinement d'accord cette photo
n'aurait jamais dû avoir lieu où l'on
loi ce que le comité miss france s'est
rendu compte que c'était une énorme
erreur tous ces gens là regardez un
accent pas masquer n'aurait jamais dû
être là il ya des risques majeurs du
coût des mises plus âgés ont dit moi je
n'y vais plus c'est terminé on nous fait
prendre des risques et le comité miss
france qui a vu que ça se passait mal ou
sûr je fais pas si vous êtes machine sur
la maison sap avec les anciennes miss si
vous êtes sur loix de sap vous avez vu
ce message mais moi la famille c'est
presque un ordre du comité miss france
qui dit texto à vous aucune
communication ne devra avoir lieu sur
cette photo nord vous étiez oui oh là là
là alors ares j'ai fait alors donc cette
photo c'est on a on a mis le doigt sur
quelque chose qui fait mal la wii
ces jeunes christophe maé qui m'envoyait
oui à respect pour les ont confié qu'ils
n'ont pas d'autorisation de travail donc
le comité miss france ou demande presque
de dire que vous avez pris cette photo
il ya plusieurs semaines ils sont en
difficulté alors j'ai un feeling ono
n'est pas venue ici pour ça mais je suis
venu pour les petits magiciens mais je
vais quand même vous répondre alors
gilles je moi je suis ravi qu'on se
revoie et oui mais voilà à noter par
contre faut pas lancer des phrases comme
ça parce que on sait tout fait tester
d'ailleurs c'est très désagréable tout
le monde s'est fait tester
heureusement mais voilà donc on s'est
fait tester c'était en comité très très
réduit même si voilà mais on sait tout
fait tester on était toutes négatives et
en plus de ça pendant le confinement les
tournages ne sont pas interdits et on a
respecté on avait les masses la regarder
pendant cette photo parce que si on
commence à hurler s'entend avec du
maquillage et des coiffures y en avait
et tous toutes les mains plongées
problème ma chère maquilleurs coiffeurs
été massivement qui était testé quand
même et enfin venir plein de gens et
c'est sûr qu'on n'aurait pas pu faire
une photo avec des masques et encore une
fois toutes les mesures sanitaires ont
été respectés ont été toutes pas pour
rien
bonne enquête gilles verdez a les bonnes
infos et delphine les faux nom j'ai
l'impression qu'il était dans le groupe
whatsapp méritez vous déchausser lui la
lune ou à celui valais c'est super
d'être je connais un
c'était un comité restreint et tout le
monde a été testé on à respecter au
mieux qu'on pouvait tout les bras duquel
il est passé incognito le gard à le
mecque
regardez rien les huit ans et trucs en
irait de soi mais seulement des
réverbères d'exiger la donne n'est plus
la clé mais c'est vrai que voilà elodie
donc c'était bien au niveau du rein donc
il s'est fait passer pour gilles verdez
plus tôt vous me conserver bien qui
n'aura miss france 2009 décembre
s'allume enfin là bas je vous le
confirme également y aura miss france le
19 décembre
ça y est c'est fait c'est bien j'ai
juste un petit truc à rappeler de cette
fameuse conversation whatsapp et je
pense que les principales intéressées se
reconnaîtront il ya un jury et c'est
important de le dire il ya un livre qui
est sorti il ya certaines filles qui
n'ont pas été représentés suffisamment
c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas les normes
aimant sur les
un peu comme les messages il a été
militant 80 c est vraiment tout le monde
n'a pas eu le même nombre de lits ni le
même nombre de photos et c'est vrai
maintenant s'il lui a essayé de faire ce
qu'elles puissent quelle poubelle a
essayé de faire au mieux s'il veut ou
geneviève de fontenay après il ya eu
faisait pas très bon cru la rédaction
mise en couple et donc il ya des filles
clairement et je pense à rachel qui a
été vraiment adoration il a été blessé
de pas être dans le livre et je la
comprends mais moi ce que j'aimerais
juste dire et j'aimerais faire un gros
bisou à toutes les filles c'est que
malgré tout ça reste un concours de
beauté on dit qu'à la famille miss
france mais l'un dans l'autre les places
à la télé sont chers bien sûr on monte
moins vite c'est une famille mais en
même temps on a tout des blessures l'une
envers l'autre parce qu'il ya quand même
la concurrence et moi ce que j'aimerais
c'est que toutes les miss pour une fois
on se voit sans caméra sans instagram et
tout et qu'on se fasse vraiment une
vraie sortie
m pour vraiment créer des vrais chômeurs
parce que ce message il est beau non
mais vous y prenez vous n'êtes plus
crédible et quelle belle fille qui elle
est crédible
la chose et moi ça c'est nombreux
jusqu'à neuf ans que j'ai été miss
france et j'ai toujours trouvé ça qu'au
final on se répond c'est uniquement pour
faire des photos ou des tournages et au
final on est où ton la concurrence l'une
envers l'autre et ça ça va bien et
j'envoie un message à tout puisque ce
qu'on pointe salut françois focus
montrer mesquin